so now what's going to happen is is that
on my mark these two are just going to
rush me okay we've done this before
they're just going to rush me
and I have to deal with it how I deal
with it however long okay just pushing
right uh pushing grabbing whatever
you're objective is to put me into the
ground or against the wall right okay
they have added incentive this time if
they catch me they will take me down
okay it's not about hurting anybody just
you know it's just a little bit more
intent this time
[Music]
okay get the two small guys
good
go
go nice go keep going come on come on
come on move move move turn turn turn
good come on out a boy good
job hey two attackers two attack
that's
[Music]
okay
yeah oh no no no no I didn't oh okay
okay I put you down no no no no no I
it's it's when I stop it okay okay sorry
yeah stop
go just like
this good right you me the
Wall come
on
go
go that's right start
again
go that's it put him in the wall all
right d it